we're joined by colleagues
from the european region and there's uh
dr heather papowitz the incident manager
for our european regional office
there is also
dr yano habik twis the head of office
for our office in
ukraine
and here in the room
we have dr
ibrahim
saucier fall
for that and we have dr adelaide
marshang the senior emergency officer
for the health emergencies
program
with this let me now
hand over to the director channel for
the opening remarks
thank you thank you christian
good morning good afternoon and good
evening
dumbledo is deeply concerned about the
unfolding humanitarian emergency in
ukraine
who is on the ground
working with our partners to respond to
assess the impact of the conflict on the
health of ukraine's people
and its health system and to deliver
essential medical supplies
from our hub in dubai
the first shipment will arrive in poland
tomorrow
including 36 metric tons of supplies for
trauma care and emergency surgery to
meet the needs of 1000 patients and
other
health supplies to meet the needs of 150
000 people
prior to the conflict doubleh
distributed emergency supplies to 23
hospitals
although our pre-position supplies in
cave
are currently inaccessible
this is an urgent need to establish a
corridor to ensure humanitarian
and supplies have safe and continuous
access to reach people in need
to support our response
who has so far released
5.2 million us dollars from our
contingency fund for emergencies
our needs for the next three months are
45 million dollars for ukraine and 12.5
million dollars to support neighboring
countries to care for refugees
anyone can contribute to support our
response through the who foundation
appeal page
by going to
www.wha foundation
and clicking on donate
we are also deeply concerned about
reports of attacks on health facilities
and health workers we have received
several unconfirmed reports of attacks
on hospitals and health infrastructure
and
confirmed incident last week in which
hospital came under heavy weapons attack
killing 4 people and injuring 10
including six health workers
we're currently in the process of
verifying several other incidents
the sanctity and neutrality of health
care including of health workers pay
transport and facilities
and the right to safe access to care
must be respected and protected
attacks on health care are in violation
of international humanitarian law
conflict ukraine had experienced a
recent
surge of cases of covet 19.
rates of testing since the start of the
conflict mean there is likely to be
significant
undetected transmission
coupled with low vaccination coverage
this increases the risk of large numbers
of people developing severe disease
critical shortages of oxygen will have
an impact on the ability to treat
patients with covet 19 and many other
conditions
at least three major oxygen plants in
ukraine have now closed
and we're seeking ways of accessing
oxygen from neighboring countries
and way
safely
to where it's needed
mass population movements are likely to
contribute further to transmission of
kovite 19
potentially increasing pressure
on health systems
in native countries as of yesterday
the un high commissioner for refugees
reported that more than 870 000 refugees
have left ukraine
and we expect that number to increase
rapidly
double a choice
countries to address key health issues
among refugees and forcibly displaced
persons
including mental health and
psychological assistance as well as
treatment for diseases including hiv tb
and cancer
who remains committed to meeting
the health needs of the people of
ukraine
now to covet 19.
it's encouraging to see that does from
kobit 19 are now declining globally
and in most regions
and it's pleasing to see some countries
being able to relax restrictions
without their health systems being
overwhelmed
but it's far too early to declare
victory over covet 19.
there are still many countries with high
rates of hospitalization and death
and low rates of vaccine coverage
and with high transmission
the threat of a new and more dangerous
variant remains very real
we continue to urge all people in all
countries to exercise caution
and we urge all governments to support
their people to protect themselves and
others
the only sustainable way out of the
pandemic is to reach high vaccine
coverage in all countries
globally
56 percent of the world's population has
been fully vaccinated
but only nine percent of the population
of low-income countries
we're now overcoming many of the supply
and delivery constraints we faced last
year
with more than 1.3 billion dollars of
vaccine delivered by kovacs
and the supply outlook for this year is
positive
we must now turn our attention to
addressing the crucial question of how
we turn
to vaccinations
how we ensure
enough tests
enough oxygen
to keep health workers safe
we call on all governments to continue
with surveillance to track the virus as
well as testing to make sure patients
receive the right treatment
to achieve all our targets we're calling
on all countries to fill the urgent
financing gap of 16 billions dollars for
the act accelerator
germany has become the first country to
pledge to meet its fair share with a
generous contribution
of 1.22 billion us dollars
finland germany
and we look forward to other countries
following your lead
we must also remember that the effects
of the pandemic go far be
and this is caused by the virus itself
in particular kovid 19 has taken a heavy
toll on mental health
a new who report estimates that in the
first year of the pandemic
the global prevalence of anxiety and
depression increased by more than 25
percent
the greatest increases in depression and
anxiety were found in places that were
the most affected by covid19
where infections were high
and social interaction was
restricted
our review found that females were more
affected than males
younger people especially those aged
between 20 and 24 were more affected
than older adults
this increase in the prevalence of
mental health problems coincided with
severe disruptions to mental health
services
and underscored chronic underinvestment
in mental health
leaving
huge gaps in care for those who need it
most
by the end of last year
some services had been restored
but too many people remain unable to get
the care and support they need
who has worked with partners to lead an
inter-agency response
to the mental health impacts
by disseminating guidance tools and
resources for responders and the general
public and by supporting countries to
integrate mental health and psychosocial
support
in their response
christian
back to you
thank you very much dr teddrus
now we come to the uh question and
answer session please raise your hand
with the raise your hand icon in order
to get into the queue and i believe i
still owe you the title of doctor saucy
fall who we have with us he is assistant
director general for emergencies
response
here at wjo at the emergencies program
so apologies for this and we start right
away with the first question
and
michael bucchio from cnn
michael please unmute yourself
uh good afternoon can you hear me
very well please go ahead
okay so i'm talking to you from the city
of lavio in west
um director general um
with the utmost respect as you may
recall i used to work for unicef
i was a spokesperson globally for a
while and also
in places like obt
um i've been hearing from
uh
staff in
various uni agency offices here in
ukraine and elsewhere
uh asking me or bringing to my attention
that in those statements including the
one you mentioned today which of course
is very useful and the world needs to
hear
that the name of the aggressor russia is
nowhere to be found
i've also found this uh in statements
with the unicef executive director
also unhcr
and i realize
in times like this it's very difficult
to call out a member state
but as we all know and verified by
you know international news
organizations and others that
children's hospitals have been targeted
schools have been targeted
places which should be safe haven for
children have been targeted
i was a spokesperson for unicef whether
it was the myanmar generals or warring
spies in the middle east we would call
them out so my question is this i'm
sorry for rambling on a bit but have we
reached a point where
where
these types of unforgivable actions are
happening before our very eyes and again
verified by credible parties that we are
not able to call out to member state
thank you very much
thank you very much and i believe we
start with dr mike ryan
um
thanks for for your commentary
we work all
around the world every night and every
day
in the service of people affected by
conflict and the conflict that is
generated by by so many aggressors
around the world be it as
in international or national conflicts
there's no doubt in this case that the
the
that he has always been on the side of
peace he speaks about health for peace
and peace for health he speaks that
there can be no health without peace he
has always done that
what we
try to do is honor the organization's
commitment to standing and be ha beside
those who are suffering
and leave the politics
of punishing perpetrators to others who
are better capable of doing that but
that is not to say that we don't uh uh
con
aggression on civilians at every
you've called out on attacks on health
care not only here but in syria and
other places and we have taken a very
strong position
uh on attacks on civilians and attacks
on healthcare
we we are not politicians
we're a health care organization
but the director general has been clear
each and every time we have come across
a situation like this to speak for the
need for humanitarian access
for people to stop fighting
for peace to be put in place so health
can be preserved so i don't think wa joe
is in any way unclear in our position on
this um and
from from our perspective
we call on the uh
the parties and and particularly uh call
on the
government of russia to reconsider its
position in the light of the suffering
that's being generated in
in ukraine
thank you very much dr ryan and next
question goes to sophie mckenna from
south african broadcasting corporation
sophie please unloot yourself
thank you
the question is directed to dr teddrus
dr teddrus as the head of the global
organization on health
your concerns around the conflict
in ukraine have you been able
to speak to the authorities
from both
countries particularly at the heads of
state level
raising your concern around allowing
humanitarian assistance or that corridor
and also the emergency supply
so that the valve
can be
assisted who are in this case
women
and children but also people from the
diaspora from different countries in the
diaspora from different countries who
are now struggling
particularly in the borders have you
been able to speak to president putin
and president zielinski to say we need
a passage or a corridor so that we can
continue with health
at the time where the world is
struggling with the pandemic
i don't know whether he's repeating
itself 2018 spanish flu it was just
immediately after they were
thank you very much sophie and dr
terrorism yeah thank you sophie uh for
that question
um
we haven't spoken to them yet but it's
very important to do that
our first shipment is arriving tomorrow
of course we have indicated today in my
statement i have indicated that
we will need a corridor to
support
the needy
so
since we are now
sending the supplies from
dubai and other hubs that that that we
have
we will engage engage authorities in
order to get
access
we had a meeting yesterday of un
agencies and one of the challenges we
have identified is
access problems and this has to be
addressed and
the right authorities should be
contacted in order
to give access
flight will be the first one but we will
have more and there will be a need
for access to those who need our support
thank you
and dr raptors
can i just supplement i think the
question you you've asked about
humanitarian corridors is very important
and i know they
you and acha and the leadership of
martin griffiths and red cross and
others are are really engaged with that
uh
priority now which is to assure
humanitarian corridors for access for
aid we've got a warehouse full of
supplies
in in
kiev
and we need to get those out we've got
oxygen supplies ready to come in from
outside we've got
very specialized
surgical equipment debridement equipment
resuscitation equipment major trauma
equipment we have
pre-positioned those supplies as the dg
said in a number of hospitals before
this and again to maybe to remind people
listening in who is not going into
ukraine we have always been in ukraine
we have been in ukraine for years
working with the government on the
health system on the health system
development on the crisis since 2014
in the nets in luhansk
we have engaged in mass casualty
management and major surgical training
in hospitals all over ukraine over the
last number of months adelaide and
others may wish to speak to that or
heather who's online we have been
preparing and working with ukrainian
health authorities we have a very deep
and the dg has a very deep and strong
relationship with ministries of health
all over the world not least of which
with the ministry of health in ukraine
are
to sustain and preserve the health
system in ukraine that it may serve the
people of ukraine and we will do
everything in our power to make that
happen but as you said we cannot do that
if we cannot get there and surge and
support our staff we cannot bring
supplies in if we cannot bring oxygen in
if we cannot distribute the supplies we
already have in the country then we are
blocked so humanitarian access
corridors moments of peace
anything that can be done to create a
situation where we can move supplies
move patients move other things will be
hugely
beneficial at this point but right now
in the chaos of what's happening there
it's very hard to see how that can be
achieved in the coming days and that's
why the tragedy unfolding for the people
is is so avoidable and so unnecessary
thank you very much for this and i'm
looking into the virtual room if doctor
heather popovich incident manager euro
as indicator wants to maybe add
thank
you put
really well um
and just to add that uh
we are there in ukraine and even though
there's access issues we're still
working directly with the government um
through cell phones um any way we can
we're coordinating partners the health
cluster is very active
we're conducting risk assessments and um
really doing what we can even if we're
not able to move around so we're still
trying to support as much as we can
access to uh emergency health care and i
don't know if yarno wants to add a
little bit more
yes please dr uh jano habit head of
office for ukraine
please thank you and uh thank you to dr
tedros uh mike heather and uh summary
and uh yes we have been working with
ukraine and we are working now and we
continue to work
and
for the
arrivals tomorrow that dr tedders also
mentioned we have agreement to use
logistics as much as possible what is
available from authorities
to ensure that we are getting all those
goods to the hospitals
closest where the needs are
but the corridors and protecting the
health care workers is the most
important and in the past day
discussions with the minister of health
is how do we ensure that health care
workers are protected so it is about
humanitarian law it is about protecting
the health care workers who have went
through last two years on
treating kovid ensuring that there is
access to care and now
this will put them under huge stress
many of them with whom i talked
yesterday are working from the shelters
have repurposed their hospitals we have
a number of cities especially in east
where
host
and the cities are isolated and in those
places necessary oxygen in the coming
weeks so
it's avoidable and very important that
the access is insured as soon as
possible thank you
thank you very much all and we move to
denise roland from the wall street
journal denise please and mute yourself
oh hello hi thanks very much for taking
my question um so it's it's on ukraine
as well um i've seen the who highlight a
problem with oxygen supplies that this
is running out in some places are there
any
underway in ukraine prior to the
fighting and i was curious about
what steps you're taking on the ground
there to reinstate that what's actually
possible at the moment thank you
thank you and ranch denise and uh we'll
go to dr habech the head of office in
ukraine for specifying here thank you
thank you and and and the three things
to mention here uh one is on oxygen
oxygen is particularly needed in some of
them uh hospitals uh which are getting
isolated
so there the treatment we need oxygen
for the treatment and for that one again
the same safe passage because um
under the current situation it's
difficult even to find drivers who are
willing to drive and to bring the oxygen
from some of the factories which still
have reserves but as was said before
three of the factories are now closed as
well so there are reserves still which
is a positive news but we need to ensure
that that oxygen reaches to their to the
hospitals where the patients are
when we talk about
medicines it really varies from hospital
to hospital those hospitals which are
isolated will
have need for different type of
medicines but also more and more the
trauma kids because this is what we see
from violence and the needs are
different
there is no time to treat about
chronic diseases but the key is to
ensure life-saving treatment
so it is the situation varies from east
to west and where
the military offensive takes place
and the third on the ipv campaign that
was taking off from the first of
february to
do the catch-up campaigns started from
the western oblasts so the public health
authorities trying to do their best in
rivne in sarcatia in other oblasts to
still continue but it is becoming very
very difficult thank you
thank you for very much for this very
good picture here and we go to dr
adelaide martian here the
senior emergency officer at
double job
thank you christian and in complement to
what jarno has already said just to
highlight that we are reviewing the
situation and the health risks on a
daily basis and indeed we have looked
into specifically what medicine
shortages we may be facing and we do
have indications
that we may have or face imminent
shortages of cancer medicines that
insulin as the arnold had highlighted
non non-communicable chronic diseases
are an issue
that the lack of insulin and not having
access to diabetes supplies can result
really in grave situations for the
people with some type of diabetes we are
looking into that and and tracking
them
and and tracking
and trying to set up a tracking system
that that will inform us of the specific
needs and medicine shortages we also see
that as the lines of controls are
changing and health facilities
are
changing in in in their way of working
possibly that we will face also issues
with getting supplies to them in the
near future
over
thank you very much for this next
question goes to moses apple blood he's
from the brussels times
please unmute yourself
yes thank you very much
i would like to come back
about ukraine you mentioned i mean the
search in the infections
before
the invasion of the start of the war and
we know has also been said before
previously that
the vaccination rates in both russia and
ukraine are very low
and as you said also that now during the
war means almost no testing going on so
i wonder that
to say
estimate to predict how
the war if it continues without an
assist however soon how will that last
influence the covet 19 situation in
ukraine
when it comes to infection rates
and the number of people which is
severely ill will need let's say
treatment
at the hospitals
which are supposed now overwhelmed by
people with war injuries who have even
been bombed
and also you mentioned that people
fleeing
on the roads and so on so lots of mass
gathering and so on uh how will that
affect i mean
the situation in ukraine yes yeah thank
you very much mozart so you're asking
about the vaccination rates on covet and
the situation for covet and
trend and the way that started in
ukraine in the beginning of february it
reached the peak in the middle of
february and started in the beginning
and reached the middle of um
in the middle of february to the peak
and we saw that actually from all the
coveted hospital beds
only 35 were occupied so let's put it
this way this time it was milder than
all the previous waves that we saw in
the autumn and spring 2021
at the same time
because we still have a lot of
vulnerable and more elderly people in
the hospitals who need oxygen support so
in those territories
where
the military offensive takes place
and where hospital
being isolated and where we don't have
access but also it's not only about
oxygen it's also about electricity it is
also about the medicines there it is
difficult we don't have exact numbers
but also as well said by adulthood and
others we are tracking the system
situation in the best possible way on
vaccination coverage and it varied when
we look to kiev city then ukraine
reached to 65 percent
of both those vaccinations
but where is the vulnerability is
donetsk and duhansk where the
vaccination coverage was reaching only
to the 20
so we see huge variation
and
before if i think back two weeks
we were preparing how to really go from
villages to reach those who are
vulnerable 65 plus population so we are
concerned especially for those who are
65 plus and to ensure that they have
vaccination coverage but
in the current circumstances
we need to assess we need to ensure that
there is a safe path to of the health
care workers to those households those
people and these are the negotiations
that need to take place at a very high
level thank you
thank you very much and uh doctor
sauciful
assistant director general emergency's
response please
thank you christian to complement uh
representative
the impact of the conflict on covenant
is already very
big because we have seen a huge decrease
in time of you know capacity to test
last week only we have seen more than 80
percent reduction in the number of pc
actors performed in the country
and
the other issue is the disruption of
health services in terms of clinical
management for covid we already talked
about the oxygen supply but the risk is
to see
very high case fatality rate as we have
seen in other conflict affected
countries like yemen where we have more
than 18 percent case fatality rate
so making sure that we have the
continuity of services because the
health workers also will leave the
hospital when it's not safe so it's very
complex and we are at risk of seeing
people dying from condition we can
really treat and this is really really
bad
when we talk about
you know i think i think the estimate uh
just uh last week was there was about 2
000 people on
oxygen high flow oxygen for co-wood in
in in ukraine there's 2000 people that
need oxygen to survive
and that number you know it hasn't
changed and in fact if anything that
number has gone up because we have
people with injuries people undergoing
surgery we need oxygen we have children
with childhood pneumonia we have women
and difficulties in labor so oxygen is
not just life-saving and co-work oxygen
is life-saving full stop
and
you need it when you need it you can't
wait till tomorrow for oxygen you can't
wait till next week you can't be put on
a waiting list for oxygen you can't
stand in a queue for oxygen
oxygen saves your life right now
and when you need it you need it
and ukraine needs that that's just one
example as sose has said but it's a very
clear example that if we do not get
oxygen into the system and other
critical drugs people will die
needlessly in in the well they're dying
needlessly to start with but
there's a secondary level of
needlessness and
when you see the images and
we've all seen them here ourselves and
you know some of us been this game a
long time and we've developed very thick
skins but when you see nurses
mechanically ventilating infants in
basements of hospitals
you know even the the toughest of us
we struggle to watch that and those
heroes
who are there those
mainly women might i add in those
basements who are
taking care of those kids
but if you're a
65 or 70 year old in an icu no one can
carry you down the stairs to the
basement so many patients in advertising
use cannot be moved and they're being
cared for by doctors and nurses while
the bombs fall around them
so
you know
it's really important that we don't just
break this down into supplies and break
this down into commodities that we have
to deliver and
corridors and we speak in these very
abstract terms around what's needed
you know the this is the
people's uh bodies and people's bones
be able to deliver life-saving care and
we
um
so
i do think
i just could not believe
the bravery
of those
they're a shining example to the world
of what
we move on to
we we know that the pandemic is far from
over
uh but is the who under pressure uh to
consider declaring the end of the
pandemic sometime in 2022 uh
particularly because uh covet 19
vaccines
will reach a surplus soon
and
probably have an impact on the
discussions at the wt
fever
it will be good to know
you know the organization will declare
in
uh contracts of pharmaceutical companies
on pricing and patents and so on
thank you
thank you very much brittany and we move
to dr maria van kerkov the intense
transmission of omicron worldwide
this variant has quickly replaced delta
in circulation and detection around the
world many countries have passed their
peak of transmission of omicron but many
have not
and we have seen in a number of
countries
the amount of death
that has been reported from omicron
has in fact been higher than it was in
the delta wave in their delta wave that
they experienced and this is because of
the sheer volume of cases that we've
seen from omicron and even though
intrinsically it's less severe than
delta the number of people that have
required hospitalization and have died
from omicron has been higher in a number
of countries and this is due to a number
of factors one is because of the the
sheer volume and the the burdening of
the health healthcare systems around the
world that are fragile from past waves
of of infection
second is because we have not reached
the vaccination coverage levels that
we've needed in all countries and in
particular reaching those who are most
vulnerable
in the countries that have seen higher
amounts of death in the omicron wave
compared to delta
we've actually seen that this is in fact
in populations who are not vaccinated
who have not received the full course
people who are of older age people with
underlying conditions and this we've
used this word avoidable a lot today
this is also avoidable so reaching the
vaccination coverage the 70
that the director general
has outlined of reaching 70 percent of
all populations in all countries it's
who within that 70 percent that is
really critical the sage recommendations
have been very clear
on who we need to target in all
countries these are people of older age
these are people of underlying
conditions these are our frontline
workers and in fact we have not reached
all of those individuals in all
countries so that is our target that is
who we are aiming to reach in all
countries and no matter what is
happening out there and the rest of the
world we still need to push vaccination
coverage as best we can while at the
same time doing everything that we can
recognizing the challenges that all
countries are facing right now and the
fact that they're in different
situations to also drive transmission
down with the tools that we have so it's
both sides of that equation
thank you very much dr van kerkov
dr brazil please
yeah thank you very much christian there
are two parts to that question of course
and i think the first one about the end
of the pandemic like maria highlighted
this is not a function of vaccination
coverage it's what's happening with the
epidemiology and the virology that
drives us and remember that the surge we
are seeing now of omicron is just the
most recent surge of this virus so it is
going to be a function of time and the
control measures that are going to tell
us when we are approaching the end of
the pandemic important point as maria
says is we have the knowledge we have
the tools to get there only if we apply
them everywhere vaccination rates become
really important because the higher we
can get the vaccination the faster we're
going to get there and drive this but
there was a second part of the question
and that was about the vaccine supply
being secured and i think we need to be
clear here we're in a situation right
now where yes we do have a lot of
vaccine increasingly a lot of vaccine
that is available that vaccine is not in
the arms of the people that need it
everywhere as as
maria highlighted and one of the appeals
the director general led 10 days ago was
for the additional financing that's
needed to make sure that the vaccines
turn into vaccinations that the tests
turn into actual testing results that
the
oxygen etc actually gets to the people
that need it and that requires another
16 billion dollars so there is also a
price tag to getting us faster to the
end of the pandemic and the last point
was just in terms of that
supply well we have supply we still have
that problem we started the pandemic
with and that is that the control of
that supply is really in very few hands
and the only way that we're going to be
able to ensure security globally in the
future is exactly as you highlight it
and that is the
more geographically and fairly
distributed means of production as well
and we are not there yet important
work's been done you saw over the last
few weeks some very important
announcements about the new who mrna hub
with in in south africa the many spokes
now off of that hub a huge effort
to move very so it's a bit of a
manhattan project in some regards in
moonshot to try and get additional
capacity built out around the world as
rapidly as possible to be able to manage
that aspect as well
thank you and dr kayla o'brien please
yeah i want to amplify some of the
things that maria was uh referring to
the 70 target is is the target for
achieving the goals uh related to to
vaccination and and reducing
transmission but most importantly
reducing disease that is severe and
death and i'll give you an example that
it's not seventy percent of just uh you
know anybody uh in the population it
really is about those who are most in
need of vaccination to protect them
directly
from disease and we're still quite a
distance from that um just an example
from the africa region
with 23 countries where about 35 percent
of the health workers have have been
fully vaccinated
similarly for those who are older adults
about 25 percent of older adults fully
vaccinated and and similar numbers a
little bit lower for those with
underlying medical conditions so the
real emphasis
in every country is about getting a
hundred percent coverage of those who
are most needing the vaccine a hundred
percent coverage of health workers 100
percent coverage of older adults 100
coverage of those who have underlying
medical conditions on the way towards a
70 coverage of the whole population so
this is really where the focus has to be
that's what will take the pressure off
the health system because that's what's
really underlying the cases that are in
hospital and the deaths that are
occurring thanks
thank you very much all and next
question goes to abdullah was wasan from
the morocco news abdullah please and
mute yourself
abdullah you hear us please admit
yourself
now
yes please go ahead
[Music]
i foreign admit i didn't get the
translation
okay abdella can i
can i ask you to repeat your question
the key part and slow please because the
interpretation has not
[Music]
let's try again
so
thank you very much and i soon be
talking about the situation in ukraine
doctor sauciful please
subscribe
foreign
[Music]
thank you very much dr susie fall
next question goes to jamie keaton from
the associated press jamie please admit
yourself
thank you for taking my question
christian and nice to see you all
i believe my question is by civilians
and others there and does it tell you
anything about the types of weaponry
that may be used um in the fighting um
in particular thank you so much
thank you very much jamie and yes we
move to dr jano habit from the ukraine
office
thank you and the first round what was
mentioned what was pre-positioned where
the trauma and surgical kits
also
what are coming in are the standard kids
that the bluetooth has which are also
aiming for the surgery trauma and all
the aspects what also mike was
describing before so these are the first
deliveries
but we are looking also to very specific
aspects like the tetanus antitoxins
which are very very important as well
what was mentioned before uh to address
the
needs related to non-chemical diseases
speed insulin what is needed
hypertensive medicines which are very
much needed but also
various
goods and medicines related to sexual
and reproductive health maternal and
child health etc so these are the
standard kits that tablocho has put
together and to ship them as fast now to
ukraine but also to other places where
they are needed
and when we look to um so these need to
get there in the place
and
currently we have not
collected the statistics what exactly is
happening in every surgery room because
we are really supporting the frontline
healthcare workers to ensure that they
are providing the life-saving treatment
and support thank you
thank you and uh looking at dr popowicz
if she wants to add something
yeah thank you um i just wanted to add a
little bit on the um
the refugees coming into surrounding
countries so right now um as the
director general said we have 870 000
people and that's probably already
changed by now coming into countries at
the border and other countries so the um
the health interventions um in the host
in the countries where people are moving
are also important so as people were in
uh ukraine they had
less access to health care because of
covid even more
um constrained access to health care due
to the conflict so they're coming into
the countries already at a more
vulnerable
so when they arrive they also need
access to primary health care for all of
the things that
um uh jarno just mentioned but also
looking at some of the disease control
as they come in we have to really scale
up surveillance in the surrounding
countries for polio for measles and also
for covid and
make sure that we prevent them so
looking at uh providing vaccines for
measles
for polio and for coven 19 is paramount
but also looking at people are going to
be crowded in certain areas to look at
the water sanitation and hygiene um to
prevent diarrhoeal diseases so
everything that
is happening in ukraine is also
affecting the other um the other
countries so it's just a it's a real
regional crisis
um so just want to have that thank you
and dr ramsey yeah and and just on that
the the
the
the supplies that are going in now are
again being
more specifically designed for the
situation as it's unfolded and escalated
so
uh the the equipment
lists the in terms of what's being
what's landing today
includes you know sutures skin graft
equipment equipment for doing major
surgery
unfortunately equipment for doing
amputations for bone grafting
for bone wiring
for all of that and i think this gives
you the graphic nature of what's
happening these are ordinary civilians
being broken
and the health system
is going to have to put them back
together again and they need this very
specialized equipment for debriding
wounds
and much
much else
and that's why we have to now obviously
shift uh to from just being general
supplies to the health system to
supplying the health system what it
needs to save patients lives who have
been injured as innocent bystanders uh
in in in a horrific conflict so we will
continue to focus on that we'll continue
to focus on getting those demands
directly out of the system we have a
surveillance system in place and again i
would like to recognize the
extraordinary leadership of dr jano and
his team on the ground our national and
international staff who've been in
ukraine
are outstanding individuals and they've
stood and done tremendous proprietary
work that we can now build on um
and continue to be in contact on a
minute-to-minute basis with our with our
staff
and with the authorities on the ground
so we need further support in that we
need further financial support we need
further logistics support in order to be
able to continue to supply
the health needs of the ukrainian system
but increasingly
unfortunately these health needs are
moving more and more towards battle
wounds and people being caught up in a
horrific conflict and all of the
horrific surgical consequences of that
for patients
all over ukraine
thank you very much for these
pictures and explanations and we move on
to arya danielle from the npr national
public radio re please admit yourself
hi there uh thank you so much uh for
this discussion
um in ukraine it sounds like there's not
yet a humanitarian corridor
and that you're urgently requesting that
but can you clarify just how much access
you do have you mentioned you need more
but are you not really able to move the
supplies in at all
thank you i think we start again with dr
harvey from the from the country office
thank you and
we can get goods in and that's a good
news and we have good collaboration with
authorities
and there is a protocol in place how to
ensure that our routes are moving from
poland to
ukraine
and further there are warehouses to use
and
in cooperation with where the
direct
military offensive is not taking place
how to move the goods so there is
certain access but as the situation
evolves that
access is decreasing and the challenge
is that where the major needs are for
the surgery trauma care what mike
described so well there we don't have
access
so we can get kids to the country but
are they getting there where they are
mostly needed in the health system
that's the question
and that's from where dr tedros also
started that we had pre-positioned some
of the goods but currently those
warehouses are not accessible thank you
thank you so much i think we have time
for one more question that goes to
adriana rodriguez from usa today andrea
now please unmute yourself
thank you so much for taking my question
it's another one regarding covet in the
situation in ukraine i mean obviously
currently there is insurmountable
devastation and suffering happening
right now but is there also a concern of
increased covet transmission followed by
severe disease and possibly more death
in the upcoming weeks not only in
ukraine but in neighboring countries
why or why not and if we are worried
about this possible consequence what can
be done thank you
um
anytime
you disrupt a society like this and put
literally millions of people on the move
then infectious diseases will exploit
that people are packed together they're
stressed
and uh
they're they're not eating they're not
sleeping properly they're they're highly
susceptible to to the impacts uh of
first of all of being infected
themselves and it's much more likely
that disease will spread so what might
be for the rest of the world a inverted
commas mild variant could be a very
different experience for someone who is
in that situation we see this all the
time in refugees we see this all the
time around the world
we see this in the middle east we see
this in africa
the
the consequences of infectious disease
in displaced people in refugees who've
been um
as i said on the move overcrowded
stressed without proper nutrition or
sleep infectious diseases exploit
exploit that
so there's no question that the disease
uh covet 19 will will it will exploit
that in in the coming in the coming
weeks um and there are fixes to that i
will leave maria and maybe bruce to to
speak to that but first and foremost to
ensure that everybody is vaccinated and
as janu said
ukraine have been doing quite well in
the vaccination uh area it still had
significant number of people to cover
and we need to try and ensure at least
that
refugees coming out of ukraine are
properly offered proper vaccination
across so as they said not just for coba
19 but and heather spoke to for other
for other diseases but within um
ukraine we also have to continue to make
our efforts to support not only
prevention but also in terms of
life-saving interventions
and our clinically generous ds is
working with heather and the team to see
how we can prioritize getting antivirals
in this particular situation this may be
one situation where
the available therapeutics may be more
life-saving than another situation so
we've been prioritizing ukraine over the
last 40 to 72 hours for extra supplies
of
uh therapeutics for covert 19 including
the newer antivirals so maybe maria can
speak to that or bruce
yeah so just to supplement what mike has
said i mean um you know obviously it's a
challenging situation we're seeing the
same images you are
and people need to do the best that they
can at the moment recognizing the
challenging situation that they're in
this virus will exploit
the current situation it has it's shown
us over and over again in the last
couple of years that it will take
advantage of any crowding
and when there aren't systems in place
when there isn't surveillance when there
isn't distancing when there isn't the
use of masks it will exploit that
and so you know the best people can do
is all we can ask right now we would
like for vaccination coverage to
continue vaccines to to continue
recognizing that that may not be
possible right now
but it needs to be pursued where
individuals are as best as they can if
they have access to masks to continue to
wear masks where they can
if that's even possible
to prevent the onward spread amongst
themselves their families their loved
ones who they're coming in contact with
i think we all recognize the challenges
but it doesn't mean we give up and it
doesn't get doesn't mean we stop trying
so no matter where people are in the
situations that they're in we will be
there to support in people who are
crossing the borders into other
countries they need to be cared for in
those other countries every single life
matters every single life
um and we need to
work as hard as we can to not only end
the the conflict but to end covet 19. so
wherever you are wherever you're sitting
and watching this right now you also
have a role to play because the
intensity of spread that we're seeing
around the world is far too high
60 000 reported deaths last week that we
know of
down from the week before but it's still
far too high in the third year of this
pandemic so even though you may be far
away from the conflict you have a role
to play in this because the virus is
spreading so please play your part wear
a mask get vaccinated be educated about
how what your own risk is and lower your
risk and support the people who are
going through this conflict in ukraine
thank you christian
adrian it's your point first as mike
said you know
infectious diseases
exploit ruthlessly the conditions
created by war
and two fronts the increase
the transmission of these diseases as
you've heard from mike you know the
crowding the conditions etc they also
increase the probability of increased
deaths
more people are vulnerable in these
settings and there's less care available
for them it's as simple as that what can
we do about it number one stop the war
want to stop the infectious diseases
stop the risks stop everything else as
mike said stop the war we have to be
super clear on that because everything
else is dealing with consequences
second thing you do though in that
setting as it unfolds is you protect
your health care system health care
systems are saying to more they're
protected by international law you've
got to protect your services
the third thing then is you try and
prioritize your vaccination for your
vulnerable your vaccination for your
health care workers mike said to try and
address the oxygen shortages take care
of people who do so you're not helpless
there are things that can be done but
you need the space to be able to do
those most importantly stop the war
secondly protect your services and
thirdly prioritize both vulnerable right
now we can't do any of those three which
makes it more challenging can try to do
a lot there's a lot of bravery heroism
ongoing as mike highlighted but
so much more needs to be done
thank you all so much for these
important words and we're slowly coming
to the hour before
i give the floor back to dr tedros for
his final remarks i'm going to give the
chance to dr jana harvey
again the head of country office in
ukraine
to uh
to close with his remarks thank you
so thank you and
really three things first thank you for
hearing about ukraine
first
humanitarian access and humanitarian law
that's what we
and respecting that is what we need to
ensure that we can support ukraine and
its health system
second really protecting the health
facilities and health care workers they
are the heroes they have been always
heroes the nurses doctors
technical staff who are moving the
canisters of oxygen around
it's hard work
but we need to protect them so that's
extremely important that they feel safer
that they can provide the care
and the third
if that situation currently and the
military offensive continues then the
situation that we will see when we meet
in a week two weeks months or two months
time
will be much worse that we discussed
today thank you
thank you so much